I guess I've just been like studying a
lot and I think uh playing in tournament
um I played in a lot of strong
tournaments over the past few months and
um most recently I think I played in a
New York nard tournament and a few
really strong tournaments before that
and I think these tournaments have
helped me not just like get experience
but just playing against such strong
players
um and I've had some like both a mix of
disappointing results and good results
so I think I guess it's just like
important to keep up like no matter what
your thoughts are and to keep playing
against these John players and I think
that's definitely helped me improve the
most in the past few months you
completed your International Master Norm
congratulations on that I was very happy
to see that and do you have any plans on
getting GM title anytime soon do you
have like exact goal to get it you know
exact date for it or you're just like
going with the flow
um yeah thank you so for the GM I'm like
that would definitely take at least
another few years if not longer but I
hope that um for now I'm just sending my
goal to improve
um like slowly and I think if I like am
able to improve then the norm should
come but if I'm still like stuck they
won't come as easily so I think like
just working on improving my skill level
is the most important thing right now
um and that's I guess sort of my uh
short-term goal playing back-to-back
tournaments are pretty tiring I know
that from my own experience how are you
feeling right now
um well I feel like a bit tired I didn't
have too much time to prepare for this
tournament just like a couple days in
between yeah um but I like this format
because for this tournament it's one
game a day so you get time to prepare in
between games I know right I don't like
us or US Open a month I feel you yeah
like two games a Day Too Much I I bet it
is especially like playing back to back
two in a row I played couple of uh
events like that tournaments like this
uh two rounds a day back to back I was
completely exhausted and you're coming
out of those tournaments and then
playing another very serious event here
so yeah but I'm glad that actually there
will be a rest day here so um there's
gonna be some like time to post like
focus on chest and relax between games
um but yeah so for this tournament I'm
like pretty excited to be playing
that's awesome I'm glad to hear that is
there anything uh you would like to
achieve one thing you would like to
achieve this year
um I guess like I will be playing in a
lot of drone tournaments
um like uh I've actually recently got
invited to uh like the
women's super Swiss or it's in the Isles
of a man yes I love Mount yeah yes so I
mean I guess like I hope that I'll be
able to like have a really good
experience here especially since it's
one of my first like serious
International tournaments um but overall
I guess it's like trying not to have too
many regrets
um like not losing gameplay thundering
uh like a piece or something
um and just trying to like improve
throughout the year but I don't have any
specific goal because I feel like if I
like that a good put a bit too much
pressure although I definitely like I
guess my main goal is Improvement
that is awesome and do you have any like
time to do something else besides just I
know you have been like playing for two
years or three years back to back and
everything do you have any other Hobbies
um yeah I actually do contest math
um and that's like something that I do
like for fun that's my main other hobby
uh I think like it's actually kind of
similar to chess in the way that you
have to think of Creative Solutions to
problems that arise
um and yeah but mostly I do spend a lot
of time on chess
um over the summer I've been playing in
like a lot of backwards
so that hasn't been too much time for
other stuff but I'm really enjoyed just
like the process that sounds great thank
you so much and good luck with the
tournament thank you
foreign